[Música]
é eu vou passar essa noite agora vou
começar a conversar com vocês sobre
bagagens para levar o futuro
mas antes de falar de suas bagagens eu
quero falar com vocês de uma viagem
eu quero fazer uma viagem com vocês e
essa viagem é uma viagem na minha
história
bom começando claro lá na minha infância
quando era pequeno na verdade menor
ainda né
aí bem pequeno lá aconteceu comigo uma
coisa que acontece geralmente com as
crianças que é a necessidade de mudar de
escola
e aí eu fui modelo de escola
cheguei na escola nova não conhecia
ninguém não tinha amigos e um dia na
aula de educação física professor falou
assim olha vocês vão algumas voltas aqui
em volta da quadra aquecendo e depois
cada um pode escolher qualquer um dos
esportes sair e praticar os esportes
como eu não conhecia ninguém e eu também
não era um bom esportista eu cheguei
professor eu falei professor seguinte
posso correr mas olhou ocorrer também no
esporte né falou pote e eu não sei como
eu passava 40 minutos da hora correta
dando voltas e aí eu fui como toda
criança foi fazendo amigos fui
conhecendo os coleguinhas e tudo e
conseguir encontrar um sport que tinha
tudo a ver comigo basquete em quadra né
na verdade assim o basquete não tem
muito a ver mas é o basquete
ele tem uma posição onde o baixinho ele
consegue atuar na posição de armador e
foi nessa posição que eu comecei atuar
então era amador e amador é interessante
porque porque ele faz a uma cesta
primeiro ele tem que treinar uma cesta
que a distância porque ele só joga à
distância
então ele treina uma cesta que vale mais
pontos vale três pontos enquanto as
outras la em um ou dois e ele também tem
uma função importante que é entregar as
bolas né passar a bola e armar as
jogadas
então eu continuei jogando nosso ensino
médio ainda fiz parte do time de
basquete mas quando terminou o ensino
médio teve que escolher a profissão
ainda bem e eu percebi que o basquete
não seria minha vida né se não hoje é
muito mais difícil mas eu quis ser
advogado
de repente depois eu pensei em fazer
psicologia acabei fazendo a faculdade de
história pensando em fazer turismo
pois é mas passando tempo te passou a
faculdade terminei a faculdade de
história tvs a pós graduação em história
do brasil e foi trabalhar numa ong como
voluntário passei três anos na ong em
2009 acontece uma coisa interessante na
minha vida que foi a minha mudança você
já deve ter percebido que eu não sou do
maranhão meu sotaque é muito diferente
quando falo porta mas eu saí lá do
paraná e cheguei aqui no maranhão e o
mais interessante ainda foi o motivo de
eu ter chegado no maranhão
o motivo foi uma namorada mais
interessante que isso foi que dois meses
depois há também um pé na bunda
olhei para ela e falei nada a ver tá eu
e nem você batendo em mim a copa
nem dado é sempre assim quem ri por
último ri melhor detectável atestar a
menina a vida e se o mundo dá muitas
voltas
e tal e em uma delas a gente vazia
contra e aí não a gente não se encontrou
né ainda bem que a gente não se
encontrou porque o seguinte esse negócio
de estar num não vale a pena e na
verdade assim a gente vai perceber que o
melhor de tudo foi ontem encontrado mas
continuando um pouco né dessa história
dessa minha caminhada aqui eu continuei
trabalhando
e aí eu resolver atuar é atoa que
maranhão e eu fui atuei como professor
já era formado em história mesmo né
professor de história sociologia e
filosofia antropologia e todas as vias
que existiam começar a aula no ensino
médio fundamental em tudo o que eu tava
eu estava dando aula mas eu percebi que
não era bem isso que eu queria fazer
comecei a aprender a fazer sites e abrir
um escritório de web design mas também
percebi que isso não era bem o que eu
queria fazer
e aí eu fiz um concurso passar num
concurso foi trabalhar como concursado e
de novo na minha cabeça começou a passar
uma coisa uma frase
peraí parece que eu continuo correndo
mas eu tô aqui pra falar com vocês sobre
bagagens e a primeira bagagem que eu
quero conversar com vocês é sobre uma
bagagem que é tá levar nas costas e em
nome dessa bagagem é experiências então
primeiro de todo leva e experiências na
sua bagagem para o futuro independente
de que você faça a eu tô fazendo uma
faculdade que eu não gosto tudo bem
aprenda o máximo nessa faculdade e
adquirir essas experiências no emprego
não aguenta o chefe beleza continuar
agüentando ele e adquira mais
experiência aprenda com isso tomei um pé
na bunda aprende né aprende talvez até
amar melhor né
hoje minha esposa pode dizer isso eu
melhorei é ela não está aqui então não
ficou muito engraçado mas
é e também ela não pode confirmar a
então eu fui na moral mas leva essas
experiências passa coisas
independente do que você esteja fazendo
traga isso como experiência
carregue isso nas suas costas a segunda
bagagem e essa é uma bagagem para você
levar do lado
então você leva suas bagagens do lado em
nome dessa bagagem são pessoas
carregue pessoas com você traga pessoas
do seu lado né e tudo que você fizer
faça por pessoas porque assim você pode
às vezes não têm uma habilidade mas
existem pessoas que têm essa habilidade
por exemplo eu gostaria muito de fazer
uma palestra com música mas não dá
só que tem o jorge aí eu isso mesmo
jorge porque é o seguinte se eu começar
a cantar aqui todo mundo vai fugir mas
seu voto de cantar
todo mundo vai querer ficar tem gente
até dançar o forró do dia melhor
toró agora minha
animado e ninguém com o china chega
passe lá pra dançar e na escola na
escrita é o que é proibido e chinchilla
é proibido é proibido cochilar
chinchilla
pois é tá vendo aí se eu tivesse fazendo
a tarefa talvez sendo a última teria
muita gente cochilando
eu tenho alguém que me ajuda aqui trazer
pessoas e agregar experiências é
importante é uma bagagem que você deve
levar um lado ea terceira bagagem bom
a terceira bagagem eu quero na verdade
continua a contar um pouco da minha
história que eu parei de contar pra
vocês
ensinou a nunca desistir negra
te procurar evoluir podem tirar tudo o
que eu tenho
só não podem me tirar as coisas boas o
que eu fiz pra quem ambos
sou feliz e canto o universo é uma
canção e eu vou que voa história as
nossas histórias dias de luta dia de
glória
a história as nossas histórias dia de
luta dia de agora a história das nossas
histórias dia domingo tardia de glória
a história da nossa história dia de luta
ia de agora então é assim é passei por
muitas coisas e perceber que nessa
correria
uma coisa importante e essa é a terceira
bagagem em 2014
resolvi ser empresário e ser bastante e
eu peguei essa bagagem na minha mão e
falei agora preciso estabelecer metas e
essas metas
elas são importantes porque elas definem
os objetivos
elas fazem você parar de correr dando
voltas e começa a correr em um jogo você
se junta a algum time e começa correto
as pessoas pegas suas experiências e
começam a focar em um objetivo isso faz
diferença
e quando eu quis ser palestrante eu
assisti a algumas palestras do ted
e eu dizia um dia eu quero estar nesse
palco
hoje eu tô aqui e mais interessante
ainda é dizer para vocês que eu me sinto
como aquele jogador aquele amador agora
não entrega bolas na entrega faz entrega
idéias e essas idéias quando fazem
diferença
eu acredito que eu faço os meus pontos
espero prefeito max mostra isso
o
[Música]
[Aplausos]